salut éternel là bas saddam cus et wes
sa bôme et tu quand c'est une croûte
avec moi où tu sma web web
monsieur voudra peut-être deux aph
monsieur façon snob parfaitement de gens
voudraient des achats et celle là même
que tout sur un plateau voulons comme
aux arts ménagers sur un pull un tournoi
long point monsieur ça une grande
assiette qui soulève à plus d'un mètre
au dessus de la table pour pierre piot
des offres la mire à quelle époque mon
violent quand et pour le manioc maïs
avec leur système
abbas fait tout seul son camp il mondo
renier ses écrans
et puis avec l'ensemble réglages les
lettres leur franchiseur kobe dix balles
qui n'aura plus besoin d'elle mais
talons ben ouais bah moi aussi c'était
aux armes lazer seulement mots je ne
pense pas qu'elle ait croûte suis un
homme d'intérieur
tiens tu ouest appareils pas si ted la
poussière si ton tapis de la spirale ex
situ vent peu de puissance
l'arc un record avec ça et si tu veux
cci souhaite pp battu l'as est toujours
avec ceux des pays cités comme moi je
t'aime le boulloche propre tu fais tu
artésienne son était saucette dans leur
machine à laver
et puis alors ils ont dès maintenant dès
maintenant qu'ils font procéder à des
descoings est maintenant très bonne au
fond y'a rien à schwedt électricité